let's play that clip this is about women
and the [ __ ] phase the whole phase
whatever you want to call it here's
Adam's opinion I I didn't wait to see
what I want you to respond to that here
and I also want to give my take on it so
let's play that one first Tyler if you
don't mind
three that
I think women 20
21 to 24. they got some figuring [ __ ]
out to do they need to date the wrong
guy they need a [ __ ] [ __ ] up they
need to go through their whole phase
like because the last thing you want to
do is get married at 22 and like you're
molded whatever I've seen this happen
before next thing you know you're 37 and
you're like I never got to party I never
got to be the girl in a yacht I never
got to bang the Latino guy in the club
whatever and then like you're gonna have
this like I wish I wish I wish so there
is a component for women to kind of get
some like get some of the stuff out of
your system and then let's say whether
it's 24 25 whatever
then you can kind of get settled into it
I'd say the exact same thing to guys but
just wait till you're in your 30s like
okay
where do I start where do I start okay
so I hear this and I just want to be
like no
um so I I just don't think it's good for
women to behave that way at all like I
don't think they enjoy it and I look
back and I'm like okay I never had that
phase where I was like oh I need to get
it out of my system and I feel like that
is something that guys go through it's
legitimate like they need to kind of
purge that but I feel like every woman
that I knew in my life who tried to
mimic that male Behavior was miserable
and really what they wanted was a
boyfriend but they couldn't find a
boyfriend so they were like oh I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna do what the guys
are doing and they were all unhappy so
and also I feel like it devalues you
then when you do go to find that guy and
they realize that you've been with all
these guys and you've been floating
around and oh my friend was with her
like a few years on this and you've just
been around a lot they're gonna be like
oh now you're like kind of low quality
because guys don't really like that in
women women who've kind of slept around
the block 50 times so I would say my I
see that and I'm like no Adam women
don't need to do that like maybe that's
something rules for guys in a way but
women aren't happy doing that they
shouldn't aspire to do that and they
should aspire to a position of
self-respect where they don't have to do
that like they don't they don't benefit
from that structure in any way and I'd
argue they don't really need to purge
that because that's not really what
we're about at our core you say what
well I definitely agree I don't think
that it's something that women have to
go through but I think right now that is
our hypersexual culture saying that this
is a rite of passage for women your rite
of passage and from becoming a girl into
becoming a woman is being ran through
essentially and we could have a counter
narrative we have had counter narratives
but right now rights of Passage for
women I think are really lacking for men
it's lacking as well but for us I know
some women that you know they'll they'll
never have that formal wedding or they
won't have a bridal shower or a baby
shower or now we have baby showers for
baby mamas and that's not what we had
before so it's just a sign of
degradation of culture but women are
believing it and eating it up and it
doesn't make any sense to me so I think
one of the reasons why I was able to get
married in the first place is that I
knocked off that behavior really young
because it was it occurred to me you
know I'm not happy doing this I do not
like these guys and it wasn't a long
time it was mostly just I think probably
being a teenager or something like that
but I was absolutely miserable and
depressed and if you bring that up to
other young women I think other young
women don't want to be faced with that
mirror that maybe you're doing behavior
and activity that's also putting
yourself down so they will try to cope
and tell you you're overthinking it just
have fun and if you look at it for what
it really is because women have this
fomo thing if you look at the dark
reality of fomo it's not really fun it's
not really fun I think the latest story
I had about fomo for myself was I was
looking at these rave girls on Instagram
and they just look so happy and so thin
and so just joyful but the reality is is
that they're probably doing a lot of
drugs and they're dehydrated at a
festival you know exaggerated you think
about it and there's STDs too so if you
look at the darkness of fomo you're not
really missing out on a whole lot but we
have to convince women of that which I
think is sad but could be a sign of
consumerism as well do you know any
women who are happy doing that because I
I look back at my life I can only think
of one person I knew who was really
comfortable kind of behaving like a like
a badly behaved guy like sleeping around
show up in somebody's bed then you don't
even know their name it's only one girl
that I encountered and she was running
from a lot of things you know she was
buried in alcohol and there were other
problems going on but I didn't know any
healthy woman at 23 24 even that was
comfortable with that it seemed like
they were all really searching for
stability and relationships and finding
themselves in instability but really
miserable so they were like repeating
the the same bad behavior over and over
again but they didn't want any of that
so is that is that like the girls that
come talk to you and say like help me
out do they feel lost in that structure
that they're told this is female
empowerment but it's actually not
feeling that way for them I think they
mostly just get relieved that they can
finally say that they don't like it and
that it's been harmful and negative to
them and that they're they're happy that
they're being presented with a different
idea and honestly I think if we could
just get to these girls a little bit
younger they would avoid it like I'm a
fairly intelligent young woman if you
would have sat me down at 15 or
something and presented me with the
statistics of marital satisfaction and
saving yourself for marriage as a woman
I'd even like oh okay that seems like a
route that I'd like to take but I just
don't think that people people are
bringing it up but I don't know any
woman that is living that lifestyle that
I think is Happy there's one that I
suspect is happy but she's also an
alcoholic though so it's hard to tell
because if you're happy then what are
you numbing yourself from it's just a
bad experiment that's mostly benefited
men
um what is it the sexual Revolution I
feel to see how men lose when we have
lower standards for access to the
bedroom and then on top of that right
they can walk away from paternity I mean
it can be as simple as child support
which can be avoided if you work under
the table but then it's also she can
just get it fixed for free over at
Planned Parenthood so I I just don't
think we ever won the sexual Revolution
I don't know why women try like why
older women try to tell other women that
it was a dub because to me it just looks
like a big fat L like what do you mean I
get to be promiscuous and then if I get
pregnant like he might not even be
around I don't know that sounds like a
like an o yeah I mean also just for our
friend Adam Adam I love you but it
doesn't make any sense because if you're
saying you want a high value woman and
you're saying that high value means that
they've been less promiscuous they've
been more selective they have more
self-respect if they're running through
it like this or whatever being run
through I don't even know the right term
for them ran through whatever sleep my
version of it back when I was youthful
was like you're just sleeping around
okay so when you're just sleeping around
that's going to decrease your value so
then you're going to have less what
who's going to be left by the time they
get to you at 25
they've already like they've they've
taken themselves down a notch so don't
the message should be you know don't
mimic this bad male Behavior if you're
what you're really you're not craving
all that stuff what you're really
craving is intimacy and you're not going
to get it by following that model the
guys doing that aren't craving intimacy
they're just like oh look boobs oh a
butt oh yeah let me just lift you
they're not like oh I'm looking for
somebody to cuddle with or wake up with
a they're not thinking of it like that
it's a different mindset if you want to
watch the full episode you're going to
click right here and if you want to ask
me a question one on one you want to do
a one-on-one FaceTime with a group of
your friends whatever you you want you
need to download manect right now click
right here and let's get talking
[Music]